[موسيقى]
من المعارضه في اكثر من 150 حيا وبلده
مختلفه في 43 ولايه تركيه والان الى بقيه
الاخبار بايجاز مع زين العابدين توفيق
[موسيقى]
شكرا وسيله اوكرانيا تتهم روسيا بشن هجوم
صاروخين على كييف واستهداف سد في دوناتك
وبقتل مدنيين جراء قصفها منشاه طبيه في
ومسؤولون روس يتهمونك بقصف اهداف مدنيه في
منطقه جنوبيه روسيا
امريكيين احتجاجا على تصريحات بشان
الهجمات داخل روسيا اطلاق نار متقطع في ام
درمان برغم بيان امريكي السعوديه اكد وجود
تحسن ملحوظ في احترام اتفاق الهدنه
بالسودان وبعد اتهامه الدعم السريع
بالتماد فيما وصفه باسري ومطارده متقاعد
القوات النظاميه الجيش السوداني يدعو
المتقاعدين وكل القادرين على حمل السلاح
يدعوهم للتوجه لاقرب قياده عسكريه لتسليحه
الى اللقاء